I'm a journalist so I like to look for
the untold stories the lives that
quietly play out under the scream of
headlines I've also been going about the
business of putting down roots choosing
a partner making babies so for the last
few years I've been trying to understand
what constitutes the 21st century good
life both because I'm fascinated by the
moral and philosophical implications but
also because I'm in desperate need of
answers myself we live in tenuous times
in fact for the first time in American
history the majority of parents do not
think that their kids will be better off
than they were this is true of rich and
poor men and women now some of you might
hear this and feel sad after all America
is deeply invested in this idea of
economic transcendence that every
generation kind of leapfrogs the one
before it
earning more buying more being more
we've exported this dream all over the
world so kids in Brazil and China and
even Kenya inherit our insatiable
expectation for more but when I read
this historic poll for the first time
didn't actually make me feel sad felt
like a provocation better off based on
whose standards is better off finding a
secure job that you can count on for the
rest of your life those are nearly
extinct people move jobs on average
every four point seven years and it's
estimated that by 2020 nearly half of
Americans will be freelancers okay so is
better off just a number is it about
earning as much as you possibly can by
that singular measurement we are failing
median per capita income has been flat
since about 2000 adjusted for inflation
all right so is better off getting a big
house with a white picket fence
less of us are doing that nearly 5
million people lost their homes in a
Great Recession and even more of us
sobered up about the lengths we were
willing to go or be tricked into going
in many predatory cases to hold that
deed homeownership rates are their
lowest since 1995 all right so we're not
finding steady employment we're not
earning as much money and we're not
living in big fancy houses Tolle funeral
bells for everything that made America
great but are those the best
measurements of a country's greatness of
a life well-lived what I think makes
Americans great is its spirit of
reinvention and the wake of the Great
Recession more and more Americans are
redefining what better-off
really means turns out it has more to do
with community and creativity than
dollars and cents now let me be very
clear
the 14.8% of Americans living in poverty
need money plain and simple and all of
us need policies that protect us from
exploitation by employers and financial
institutions nothing that follows is
meant to suggest that the gap between
rich and poor is anything but profoundly
immoral but too often we let the
conversation stop there we talk about
poverty as if it were a monolithic
experience about the poor as if they
were solely victims part of what I've
learned in my research and reporting is
that the art of living well is often
practiced most masterfully by the most
vulnerable
now if necessity is the mother of
invention I've come to believe that a
recession can be the father of
consciousness it confronts us with
profound questions questions we might be
too lazy or distracted to ask in times
of relative comfort how should we work
how should we live all of us whether we
realize it or not seek answers to these
questions with our and
Chester's kind of whispering in our ears
my great-grandfather was a drunk in
Detroit who sometimes managed to hold
down a factory job he had as
unbelievable as it might sound 21
children with one woman my great
grandmother who died 47 years old of
ovarian cancer now I'm pregnant with my
second child and I cannot even fathom
what she must have gone through and if
you're trying to do the math there were
six sets of twins so my grandfather
their son became a traveling salesman
and he lived boom-and-bust so my dad
grew up answering the door for debt
collectors and pretending his parents
weren't home he actually took his braces
off himself with pliers in the garage
when his father admitted he didn't have
money to go back to the orthodontist so
my dad unsurprisingly became a
bankruptcy lawyer couldn't write this in
a novel right he was obsessed with
providing a secure foundation for my
brother and I so I asked these questions
by way of a few generations of struggle
my parents made sure that I grew up on
kind of steady ground that allows one to
question and risk and leap and
ironically and probably sometimes to
their frustration it is their steadfast
commitment to security that allows me to
question its value or at least its value
as we've historically defined it in the
21st century so let's dig into this
first question how should we work we
should work like our mothers that's
right we've spent decades trying to fit
women into a work world built for
company men and many have done back
bends to fit in but others have carved a
more unconventional path creating a
patchwork of meaning and money with
enough flexibility to do what they need
to do for those that they love my mom
called it just making it work today I
hear life coaches call it a portfolio
career whatever you call it more and
more men are craving these hole
if not harried lives they're waking up
to their desire and duty to be present
fathers and sons now artists and
Hamilton has said labor is a way of
knowing labor is a way of knowing in
other words what we work on is what we
understand about the world if this is
true and I think it is then women who
have disproportionately cared for the
little ones and the sick ones and the
aging ones have disproportionately
benefited from the most profound kind of
knowing their is knowing the human
condition by prioritizing care men are
in a sense staking their claim to the
full range of human existence now this
means the nine-to-five no longer works
for anyone punch clocks are becoming
obsolete as our career ladders whole
industries are being born and dying
every day it's all nonlinear from here
so we need to stop asking kids what do
you want to be when you grew up and
start asking them how do you want to be
when you grow up their work will
constantly change the common denominator
is them so the more they understand
their gifts and create crews of ideal
collaborators the better off they will
be the challenge ahead is to reinvent
the social safety net to fit this
increasingly fragmented economy we need
portable health benefits we need
policies that reflect that everyone
deserves to be vulnerable or care for
vulnerable others without becoming
destitute we need to seriously consider
a universal basic income we need to
reinvent labor organizing the promise of
a work world that is structured to
actually fit our 21st century values not
some archaic idea about bringing home
the bacon is long overdue just ask your
mother now how about the second question
how should we live we should live like
our immigrant ancestors when they came
to America they often shared apartments
survival tactics childcare always knew
how to fill one more belly no matter how
small the food available but
we're told its assessment leaving the
village behind and pursuing that iconic
symbol of the American Dream the white
picket fence and even today you know we
see a white picket fence and we think
success self possession but when you
strip away a sentimentality what it
really does is divides us many Americans
are rejecting the white picket fence and
the kind of highly privatized life that
happen within it and reclaiming village
life reclaiming interdependence instead
fifty million less for example are
living in intergenerational households
this number exploded with a Great
Recession but it turns out people
actually like living this way two-thirds
of those who are living with multiple
generations under one roof say it's
improved their relationships some people
are choosing to share homes not with
family but with other people who
understand the health and economic
benefits of daily community Co abode an
online platform for single moms looking
to share our homes with other single
moms has 50,000 users and people over 65
are especially prone to be looking for
these alternative living arrangements
they understand that their quality of
life depends on a mix of solitude and
solidarity we just really true of all of
us when you think about it young and old
alike for too long we've pretended that
happiness is a king in his castle but
all the research proves otherwise it
shows that the healthiest happiest and
even safest in terms of both a climate
change disaster in terms of Prime all of
that are Americans who live lives
intertwined with their neighbors
now I've experienced this firsthand for
the last few years I've been living in a
CO housing community
it's 1.5 acres of persimmon trees you
know this prolific blackberry bush that
snakes around a community garden all
smack-dab by the way in the middle of
urban Oakland the nine units are all
built to be different different sizes
different shapes but they're meant to be
as green as possible so big shiny black
solar cells on our roof mean our
electricity bill rarely exceeds more
than five bucks in a month the 25 of us
who live there are all different ages
and Pluto
persuasions and professions and we live
in homes that have everything a typical
home would have but additionally we
share an industrial-sized kitchen and
eating area where we have common meals
twice a week now people when I tell them
I live like this people often have one
of two extreme reactions either they say
why doesn't everyone live like this or
they say that sounds totally horrifying
I would never want to do that so let me
reassure you there is a sacred respect
for privacy among us but also a
commitment to what we call radical
hospitality not the kind advertised by
the Four Seasons but the kind that says
that every single person is worthy of
kindness
full-stop end of sentence the biggest
surprise for me of living in a community
like this you Cheryl the domestic labor
the repairing the cooking the weeding
but you also share the emotional labor
rather than depending only on the
idealized family unit to get all of your
emotional needs met you have two dozen
other people that you can go to to talk
about a hard day at work or troubleshoot
how to handle an abusive teacher
teenagers in our community will often go
to a parent that is an adult that is not
their parent to ask for advice it's what
bell hooks called revolutionary
parenting this humble acknowledgement
that kids are healthier when they have a
wider range of adults to emulate and
count on turns out adults are healthier
too it's a lot of pressure trying to be
that perfect family behind that white
picket fence the new better off as I've
come to call it is less about investing
in the perfect family and more about
investing in the imperfect village
whether that's relatives living under
one roof a cohousing community like mine
or just a bunch of neighbors who pledge
to really know and look out for one
another
it's good common sense right and yet
money has often made us dumb about
reaching out the most reliable wealth is
found in relationship the new better off
is not an individual prospect at all in
fact if you're a failure or you think
you're a failure I've got
good news for you you might be a success
by standards you have not yet honored
maybe you're a mediocre earner but a
masterful father maybe you can't afford
your dream home but you throw legendary
neighborhood parties if you're a
textbook success the implications of
what I'm saying could be more grim for
you you might be a failure by standards
you hold dear but that the world doesn't
reward only you can no I know that I am
NOT a tribute to my great grandmother
who lived such a short and brutish life
if I earn enough money to afford every
creature comfort you can't buy your way
out of suffering or into meaning there
is no home big enough to erase the pain
that she must have endured I am a
tribute to her if I live a life as
connected and courageous as possible in
the midst of such widespread uncertainty
we may in fact be insecure but we can
let that insecurity make us brittle or
supple we can turn inward lose faith in
the power of institutions to change even
lose faith in ourselves we can turn
outward cultivate faith in our ability
to reach out to connect to create turns
out the biggest danger is not failing to
achieve the American dream
the biggest danger is achieving a dream
that you don't actually believe in so
don't do that do the harder more
interesting thing which is to compose a
life where what you do every single day
the people you give your best love and
ingenuity and energy to aligns as
closely as possible with what you
believe that not something as mundane as
making money is a tribute to your
ancestors that is the beautiful struggle
thank you